how to go rest my name is and welcome
back to episode two of wolf football's
[ __ ] and welcome back to episode 2 of
the wolf
mungus all right I can't wait to see
what's up with the fricken what happened
I don't even know all right let's just
hear before it starts
she used duct tape yes that's it
wait what is this okay it's a fake snow
why does she look so pissed what the
hell was going on down there Big B well
you know a prisoner like that I thought
you were dead I thought you're dead snow
and that makes it okay well I don't know
I was pretty pissed I guess I hope it
was worth your time how are you not dead
how are you not dead yeah you're gonna
have to explain this cuz I'm really not
getting it yeah yeah me neither
after our conversation in the taxi last
night I got a call from toad he said his
son found a body we thought it was faith
at the time getting her back here wasn't
easy but hopefully we'll find something
on her to help us track down the killer
what that what the hell least to figure
out who she is I should have been there
I should have been there snow yeah I
tried calling the business office but
there was no answer I couldn't find you
or anyone so I took care of it
don't trust this man yeah what's
happening smell what is it
are you okay are you gonna be okay I
mean with all that's happened I'll be
fine I just want to get to the bottom of
this how is he alive what is it I just I
feel responsible in a way she looked
just like me and maybe that's why she
was killed
wait so he wasn't her ah well it's not
your fault huh
snow it's not your fault but she looked
just like me that can't be a coincidence
who was she have to find out who did
this and why she was glamoured to look
like me oh there we go thank you
that's what it is right so what's our
next move so many mysteries we keep
watching keep doing what we've been
doing we do our jobs and I'm supposed to
do what sit around the business office
twiddling my thumbs that's too dangerous
bad wolf to solve all my problems it's
too dangerous out there too dangerous
big bi yeah you almost got killed girl
come on I'm not going to be an errand
girl for crane anymore that's not what I
can't want you to be careful I almost
lost you why it's not yours to lose Oh
SAS ouch ouch my heart just oh I'm sorry
oh my little wolf heart oh no I did you
know it's dangerous but I'm not helpless
I can take care of myself I've been
doing it for centuries
TJ is waiting inside he was so freaked
out last night he wouldn't tell us much
even now he just stops talking all
together after a certain point he's
pretty shaken up though so try not to be
too - why
me myself right like his shoes man some
good shoes mein how does he fit in those
fell like he has tiny feet is that a
frickin Rhino on the wall
oh yeah we're down in the basement he's
so black oh hey Jase over there I don't
know if you want to talk to him first or
after but let me know when you're ready
to see the body
I I want to be there okay
we're back down again do you have a
second of course miss no we're gonna
talk to everyone here but we're gonna
start with the lamp I love me some lamps
ma'am
so is that that guy in that I'd rub the
lamp man really why would you put a lamp
god damn it alright let's talk to these
all right you guys have some explaining
that's enough mirror finish character
what the hell are you doing thought you
had to rhyme to the middle then get
stroppy with me Sheriff what's going on
I saw what you did down there is that
how you treat your prisoners I'd be
lying if I said I didn't want to get
tweedle do you could smack after what he
put me through but what you did to him
was way over the bloody line [ __ ]
blue rarely punished a man hurt me
little boy he saw everything
oh yeah that okay mr. toad now I want an
explanation and what did you expect to
see I thought maybe I'll catch you on
the [ __ ]
but I saw something worse didn't I
that's enough
mr. toad I deeply regret the distress
this has caused you in your son but
right now we need to carry on with the
investigation I will be happy to speak
with you about your concerns later but
you must understand how urgent this is
we need to talk to TJ this ain't over
Big B
TJ
it's alright Oh ready to talk to mr.
wolf he's gonna bond sorry every funny
I'm dissing watch yourself big P you do
anything to hurt me boy
why would he do that in front of you I
don't usually kill him when you're not
looking
alright this won't take long won't take
long don't worry go ahead DJ hi go
swimming at night sometimes in the river
oh my god it's climbing boys bad I
promise
oh where does Connie if she weren't we
know you're a good kid TJ you're not in
trouble don't worry
I can't be mad at climby I was there
under the big blocks and I heard noisy
feet and when I hear that I'm supposed
to go underwater and stay real still and
quiet that's right son then I saw height
I saw the lady milady what the hell was
it so guys take your time take your time
the lady fell in but but she didn't have
her head on why didn't everyone keep
loosing their head I thought she was
gonna pull me down too cuz cuz she had
rocks on her feet and she kept falling
down at the dark bards
cinderblocks tied to her ankles
is there more TJ he's a true you know
when people are lying
I heard you could do that that's why
you're the sheriff well it's my job
yeah part of my job is being able to
tell when people are lying I'm really
good at it is there something else you
want to say please don't be mad
what is it TJ alright I didn't stay
under the water what I know I'm supposed
to but I was scared and I went to the
top again I couldn't help it Oh gave you
very specific rules you have to stay
quiet and out of sight or bad things can
happen
I told you it's dangerous out there if
someone saw you he's not intimate in
trouble look Ali's note not this time
toad so you didn't stand her water I
don't know if anyone saw me but but
someone said stop laughing and then I
was scared and I went under for as long
as I could wait you heard someone yes
what didn't you tell us before I didn't
want to be in trouble did you see who it
was no okay whose voice were there do
you know whose voice it was no well
goddamn it someone have it you're anyone
laughing I don't know I don't know well
you don't know [ __ ] do you oh hey Pitts
from the future hair so the frog part
got a little [ __ ] up don't know what
caused it
it's taking me hours to figure out and
it's just like [ __ ] five seconds Oh
lost footage so allow me to draw what
happens in these five seconds frog is
like blah um decide because I saw Chet
and and wolf is like yeah
okay and then the girl said snow is like
oh he's so good with kids I'm gonna [ __ ]
he something like that
hey Pitts from the future again god
dammit I'm really sorry bris I'll try
and get to sorted but for now the mirror
didn't get it was any information at all
he's like I'm a dick in a mirror and
then I went to Snow White and Snow White
is like you want to shake the body or
what and I'm like yeah well I guess I
gotta do it then then we go down in this
creepy basement thing where the body was
dumped in the well or whatever and yeah
Wow
I didn't realize I've never seen her
face before now mrs. weird yeah the
glamour is so effective it's invasive
but just do what you need to do okay
let's check the brooch brooch oh
whatever
that's weird I don't wear a brooch like
that
there you go B it really belonged to her
not part of the glamour looks like
something from the homelands rough can
do you recognize these symbols no
nothing I've seen before I bet we're
gonna see it in that book that we look
throws like faiths did did doctor
Swinehart ever get back to you about
faith no he said he wanted to run more
tests
if the neck wound was the same there
might be a ribbon in her mouth - oh no
gross
draws man nothing so it's not exactly
the same can you close her mouth yeah
that looks really awkward man like
thanks all right
finally we shall she got your perfume
right how would she know how do you know
what perfume I wear you can't fool this
nose that's a fair thing but I thought
we may see that could be a bruise yeah
just look like a bruise
okay oh so we could investigate more
those are claw marks
Oh rope - height up I am tied cinder
blocks to her ankles so she would sink
Oh track marks
she used Mundi drugs I'm stay away
pretty heavily - I hear they only go for
the legs if they've used up the veins in
their arms or if they're trying to hide
the marks anyway it means it's not a
perfect match to your leg
unless don't be ridiculous maybe she was
trying to compensate with that perfume
wait
if the glamour is supposed to make her
look like me shouldn't it be concealing
things like track marks that brooch -
why would it change everything else
I've never seen one this poppy it might
be a cheap glamour and chic one just to
get the job done
the witches upstairs know what they're
doing that's why they cost so much
unless someone is making Glamour's
illegally it's not technically illegal
miss it's not encouraged for sure but
there aren't any laws specifically
forbidding it so there's some sort of
black market for Glamour's one would
assume so I imagine anyone with access
to the proper books and training could
theoretically produce a glamour yet
another thing to worry about black
market or not it's a pretty good match
look at that the buttons aren't exact
either there's an extra one here yeah
that's what I was gonna say let's look
at her fist too it looks like he's
holding something her fist is clenched
so she fought back no marks on the
knuckles Oh maybe she was grabbing
something maybe check inside aah
let's leave it alone for now you're
right these buttons are wrong I wonder
what yeah why
uh mind if I open the car now do you
mind if I open her coat
well gotta get it be it's just like me -
yeah it's so awkward all right what do
we get
it's not you it's not you snow it's just
a body nice panties by the way I'm sorry
that took longer than expected what have
you found out
well her glamour wasn't performers
defective Oh
defective we are thinking it's black
market you should really be regulating
this kind of thing yes we should keep
going seriously I have to look at that
I'm sorry I'm sad I'm not sorry at all
actually are you wearing silk lingerie
ssin why do you want to know no reason
just trying to see if the clothes are
exact yeah they're not Kat damn it
that the perfume use this Otis though
she had the perfume with her looks like
someone picked it out for so someone
gave her instructions anyone seem like
it I've seen things like this before
it's definitely magic though witches
don't usually craft objects these days I
don't think it's wise to fool around
with that it's some kind of black market
magic who knows what it could do we
should have it looked at just to make
sure it isn't dangerous don't you think
yeah it's fine it may be right one way
to find out
stop him what there's something in here
how do we open it you mind what I might
want to stand back if you're worried
crane I'm gonna try to open it something
I do with these rings here oh it's a
puzzle yeah I love puzzles
all right let's solve this [ __ ]
it looks like a moose doesn't eh yep
okay then you go down a little bit more
thank you thank you
there we go that's one sexy moves man
hey here what does that mean oh that's
probably used for the glamour is that
it's your hair yeah some freaking Harry
Potter [ __ ] man look at this
someone must have taken this from my
apartment I noticed it was missing but I
didn't think this was the last picture I
had of rosin me my sister and I don't
talk much anymore
who did this Big B oh she aunt then it
returned to normal
she's a troll goddamn that's ugly how
did she fit into those panties holy [ __ ]
calm ban alright you can calm down it's
not like you haven't seen a troll before
who is shy haven't actually thought
about all that wasn't there before
yeah who do you think she is I don't
know many trolls I'm afraid should have
left them all back in the homelands you
don't mean that do you
oh snap maybe Holly yeah maybe that
Holly guy owner of the trip Trent
no she looks a little oh no what is it
what it's not Holly it's her sister Lily
she was reported missing but it I guess
it just slipped through the cracks you
don't do your job at me or give me Holly
right who knows she might know something
about this who Lily was seeing well
certainly another troll how do you know
are you ready to race it he's a raisin
he'll [ __ ] go he's a racer hahaha why
not yeah it's too dangerous
someone tried to kill you Big B you
can't let her go out there with you it's
up to snuff her life at risk
snow wants to come with me I'm not gonna
stop her but we should leave now you
ready yeah
she's safe as long as she with me all
right
I hope all right it would seem we would
have to end this episode here I want to
thank you boys for watching I'm feeling
a little better today thank you but I'm
still not quite back yet and anyway
thank you boys for showing your support
in this series live like if you're
excited for the next episode I really
appreciate it hit the sky Cobra today I
see you both tomorrow with a new episode
stay awesome as always let me breath
you